[Music]
even if you've never touched a Zelda
game in your life it's likely that most
of you will at least know who Zelda is
right that's right it's the beloved
princess the series is named after yet
somehow never serves as the main
protagonist unless you count the she
didn't deserve this but that's not canon
so screw that Princess Zelda is what she
is a princess seemingly and endlessly
bound to serve as the damsel in distress
in some shape or form but she also does
some awesome stuff of her own like
creating glowing balls and sealing away
ancient demon warlords but the big
question here is will we ever see Zelda
become Queen as far as the main line
Zelda cannon goes Selda has never been
Queen at least not in game even when the
rest of the elusive royal family is
nowhere to be seen with breath the wall
- there is an opportunity here that we
might actually see this finally come to
fruition since well everyone including
the rest of the royal family is dead and
the kingdom has remained leaderless for
the past 100 years but before we dive
into the possibilities for breath the
walls highly anticipated sequel let's go
over some of the history of Zelda's
matriarchy the complexity of the royal
family in general and how zelda with the
highest of royal titles has eluded us so
far now it's obvious that zelda has been
queen on multiple occasions off screen
that is to say in-between games but as
one of the central characters of the
series it's a bit of a shame that zelda
only gets promoted after the credits
roll the series isn't called The Legend
of Princess Zelda after all I would love
to see her in the position of power for
once and see how she would rule the
kingdom of Hyrule because so far the
kings of Hyrule have been rather idiots
when it comes to ruling over the land I
know let's hold a competition of
strength and might and the victory would
surely be able to kick all of our asses
is allowed to touch this legendary blade
which when pulled from this box would
bring upon destruction to this entire
Kingdom and thus should never fall into
the hands of evil hello there
[Music]
but my leech can you imagine the
potential this technology has for this
kingdom for years to come
nope bury it all oh and be a good man
and chase away the sheikah chaps that
helped us in the war but my league
like I said idiots there seems to be
something strange going on with Queens
in zelda lore in general as we never
actually see them they are always absent
we have seen kings in the flash as early
as a link to the past and subsequently
in the Wind Waker and to Kings in the
Minish Cap that being the spirit of King
Gustav and the present-day King Dahl
tiss yet in all instances no Queen by
their side nor are they even referenced
or mentioned ever
that is until breath of the wild even
though we don't know what she looked
like or even her name this is the first
time in the history of zelda canon that
the existence of a queen is actually
acknowledged proof of this lies within
both creating a champion which refers to
Zelda's mother as Queen on multiple
occasions as well as our BOCES diary in
the champions ballad dlc in witcher Bosa
states quote it is always a pleasure to
see the queen of hyrule I told her that
zelda is sure to grow up into a
dignified and beautiful queen just like
her mother
now fantasy stories and fairy tales tend
to simplify the aspect of royalty with
good reason of course since a lot of it
is partially aimed towards kids we
simply have a king and a queen easy as
that in real life however royal families
are a lot more complicated I won't turn
this into an entire history lesson but
one of the basic things to know is that
there isn't always a king and queen
involved for instance Britain has a
queen but no king the Netherlands has
both but why this has to do with
historical and patriarchal traditions
it's a bit similar to the old fashioned
custom where a woman inherits her
husband's last name upon marriage when a
woman marries a king she tends to
receive the ceremonial title of Queen or
queen consort but let's just keep it
simple however when it's the other way
around the man does not inherit the
title of king but rather Prince there's
only a few rare examples where an
exception was made and the husband was
granted the title of king which
why Queen Elizabeth's husband is called
Prince Philip well technically his full
title is this but let's not go there
it's Prince and just in case you were
wondering since this is a Japanese
series it works the same way in Asian
cultures as well except here instead of
a king or queen
it's called Emperor or Empress but the
title of prince and princess are the
same going back to zelda as stated
before she obviously has been queen in
the past just not for us the player to
see after the Minish Cap she would no
doubt be crowned after king daughters
passes or gives up the title after
ocarina of time she would eventually
become queen in all three timeline
branches and in the downfall and idol
branch rather quickly as the king of
hyrule is implied to have died during
ganondorf's attack on hyrule castle
furthermore after the events of a Link
to the Past she will eventually become
Queen which leads into a link between
worlds in Phantom Hourglass after the
founding of new Hyrule and after the
defeat of Ganondorf in Twilight Princess
just to name a few in each game where we
see a descendent of Zelda it's clear
that at some point before all of this
the previous incarnation of zelda
married and eventually had offspring
since the bloodline of goddess hylia
would have ended if she didn't in
between some games there's even multiple
generations of royalty as an example in
Spirit Tracks the Zelda we see here is
not the daughter of tetra but rather her
granddaughter keep that in mind for
later the closest we've seen Zelda to
becoming Queen was in Twilight Princess
this game is set to take place more than
a hundred years after Ocarina of Time
and Majora's Mask and there's no
appearance or even mention of any other
royal family members besides Zelda
herself she seems to be at the steering
wheel alone and has the soldiers under
her command yet is still referred to as
princess multiple times in game she's
also the one to issue the surrender of
the kingdom to Zant something a princess
wouldn't have the authority to do under
normal circumstances turns out that
Zelda was on the brink of becoming Queen
but the invasion of Zant prevented this
from happening without an official
coronation ever taking place she
remained with the title of princess
throughout the events of the game as a
matter of fact it's highly likely that
the gift link was supposed to deliver to
hyrule castle at the beginning of the
game which is the sword crafted by
Russell was part of Zelda's crowning
ceremony and we find even more
information of this in a more unusual
place that being that's why lie princess
trading card deck which didn't even know
existed to be completely honest the deck
holds a total of 86 cards of which 22
are character cards the description on
Zelda's card reads she is shortly to be
crowned queen of Hyrule which indicates
that the previous king or queen has
recently passed away making her next in
line for the title so close but yet so
far when I said that we've never seen
Zelda as Queen in game that's actually
not completely true we have it's just
that it's not canon in Hyrule warriors
zelda is confirmed to be queen by
producer yusuke hayashi who states quote
in Hyrule warriors Princess Zelda is
actually Queen Zelda
she has an army as a queen would and
link is a trainee but as the story
unfolds the relationship between the two
greatly changes additionally our numa
also mentions this in an interview quote
we definitely change how zelda is used
and position her where it's best for the
experience that is as Queen and one of
the playable characters in Hyrule
warriors we also have another instance
in which we see Zelda becoming Queen
however this one is even less canonical
than Hyrule warriors it comes from the a
Link to the Past manga written by
Shotaro Ishinomori and published in 1992
it's an alternate version of the events
from a Link to the Past at the end of
the story
Zelda has become Queen and Link is the
head of the Royal Guards and Knights of
Hyrule it even states that this success
is bittersweet as their duties keep them
apart even though they were one so close
and sharing an adventure and even coming
together in dreams again this is of
course not part of the main line zelda
canon it's nice to know it exists but
i'm not counting it as a confirmation
for the title of queen for our beloved
princess now i don't want to overthink
this too much since we are dealing with
a fantasy series here but one thing that
i started to wonder about while writing
this script was how does all this tie
together with the bloodline of goddess
hylia historically we don't know whose
eldest previous husbands were though it
is hinted that in some cases this could
have been linked himself
so for this example let's satisfy the
selling fans among you for a little bit
my question would be what if Lincoln
Zelda had a son and only a son does the
power of the goddess continue but simply
skips the son until eventually a female
is born later down the line because
similar to how the hero is always male
the one to possess an awakened highly a
sealing power has always been female so
this seems to be a key element to this
whole goddess thing
the reason I'm posing this question is
because going back to spirit tracks
during the final confrontation with
maladies Zelda prays to receive the
power from goddess hylia but not from
her mother but rather Tetra her
grandmother this seems to suggest that
tetra might have had a son who
eventually became king of new Hyrule and
then continued to have a daughter that
being the Zelda from Spirit Tracks it
only makes sense that of the Royal pair
only one of them carries the bloodline
of goddess hylia because you know incest
and all but let's assume that Hyrule's
royal family are decent people who do
not resort to such abominable customs we
see something very similar in breath of
the wild rather than her mother
Zelda mentions while praying at the
spring of wisdom that it was actually
her grandmother who possessed the power
of the goddess
this is led fans who believe that
Zelda's mother married into the royal
bloodline and has no connection to
goddess heylia herself by that
definition zelda has inherited this
divine power from King Rome's side of
the family since if it was from her
mother side the Queen would have had
highly espouse as well so in this case
the power was passed from Rome's mother
to him however never awakens within him
because of the conflicting genders
I guess hence the power ultimately lands
on Zelda when she is born now let's
close off this video with breath the
while to saving the best for last
because of the great calamity Zelda is
the only living member left of the royal
family of Hyrule if there's any chance
for the kingdom to persevere Zelda would
at some point have to become queen
depending on how much time has passed
between breath one and two she might
already carry the title who knows if not
then her official coronation will
probably take place at the end of the
game since you know priorities and all
Nintendo could of course do the same
they always do in heifers Elda become
queen after the end and leave it off
screen for our imaginations to fill in
but I personally think it would be great
if we finally see it happen with our own
eyes even if it's just during the
credits when meeting the spirit of
Zelda's father King roam Basra Rama's
Hyrule he carries the title of the last
king of Hyrule the last king maybe but
last Queen
hopefully not now it could of course be
that Zelda feels no motivation to
establish a new monarchy but this would
contradict her statement during the true
ending where she says that she wants to
restore the kingdom to its former glory
and perhaps even beyond a kingdom needs
proper leadership and who else then the
last remaining member of the royal
bloodline to fulfill that role and going
back to Zell Inc for a moment perhaps we
will see a link in a position of power
for a change a royal prince rather than
a knight I mean there's obviously
something going on between those two am
i right assuming that both will survive
Ganon's onslaught I couldn't see a more
fitting ending than Ganondorf finally
being defeated once and for all and a
royal wedding at the end between the two
most iconic characters to chime in a new
era in the Zelda franchise thanks a lot
for watching everyone
before I leave it's time to introduce my
latest patreon supporters we have a
whole bunch of new faces so please
welcome Julia Franken Thomas W Drury
Almudena Carrasco Pazzo's I hope I said
that right Lucy Ganon Tristan van
dhansak Jack Thomas Jax powers Twilight
Wolf oh Jessica Chapman Rachel Mills
Milo 90 Dante's Sevilla and dusty day a
big thanks to each and every one of you
for joining this is just awesome see you
all next week and continue to stay safe
this is Don signing off and have a good
one